welcome back everyone this is part three
in our series on presenting your
research we're going to talk about the
process of publishing an NLP which
really comes down to the NLP conference
submission process given that so many of
the top venues in the field are actually
conferences
I'll say at the start that I think
there's a lot to like about the
publishing process in NLP but it also
has it's truly bewildering aspects so
I'm going to try to be a kind of trusted
guide for you through this often strange
process
let's begin with one of the most unusual
things of all the ACL anonymity period
the ACL conferences have adopted a
uniform policy that submitted papers
cannot be uploaded to repositories like
archive or made public in any way
starting one month from the submission
deadline and extending through the time
when decisions go out
for specific conferences check their
sites for the precise date when this
embargo goes into effect and I'd go one
step further I would say check the
precise hour when the policy goes into
effect and make sure you know exactly
what they mean by posting time is it the
time that you submitted or the time it
appeared as you get very close to this
deadline you might really care about
these fine details
the policy is an attempt to balance the
benefits of free and fast distribution
of new ideas and new results against the
benefits of double-blind peer review I
think the scenario that guides this is
the one where you imagine a reviewer
gets their assignments and they check
out the paper titles and then they look
over at their Twitter window and they
learn from some tweets exactly who wrote
one of their papers and what institution
it comes from and then they feel
conflicted as reviewers we want to
prevent that from happening while
balancing this idea of free expression
of ideas
for more on the policy and its rationale
I refer you to the page that I've linked
at the bottom of this slide
let me editorialize for a minute I think
that the ACL anonymity period idea was a
noble experiment but it's a failed
experiment we should move on from it
there are a few reasons I feel this way
first you have a lot of unproductive
discussions around exactly what it means
to have the period kick in and whether
you met it and what you can do during
that embargo period in terms of talks
and so forth
that's just a messy process I'm more
worried about the fact that if you post
a paper and Discover it has a mistake
you can't update the paper until the
Embargo period ends and that's just
straightforwardly unproductive because
now we have known false results out
there that can't be updated when in fact
we should want to correct the record as
fast as possible
and the third thing is that I think it
is just fed into the hype cycle what
people do now to avoid the Embargo is
published very quickly on archive to
meet the deadline even if the ideas are
Half Baked so it's a lot of flag
planting and it's leading people to feel
ever more frantic about these deadlines
when what we want instead is a more
deliberative pace for the pace for the
field
with the anonymity period out of the way
let's suppose that you are now going to
take the act of submitting you submit
your paper along with area keywords that
help determine which committee gets your
paper
this will depend very heavily on the
conference and the year in terms of
picking keywords it would be great if
you found an expert who could consult
with you a little bit on which ones to
pick so that you get the optimal
reviewers for your paper
increasingly you also need to fill out
very long and complicated checklists for
various things the community cares about
try to find an expert to help with this
these are often very extensive
checklists with complicated questions if
you fully invested in them you could
spend 12 hours filling out the form it
might be that no one is really going to
study the form that might be a
misallocation of your own time and
energy so you could have the expert tell
you which questions are likely to matter
and which ones can be filled out with
sort of basic pointers into the content
of the paper
reviewers once the submissions are all
in scan a long list of titles and
abstracts and then bid on which ones
they want to do at this stage the title
is probably the primary factor in
bidding decisions the reason I say that
is that as a reviewer you might be
facing a list of 500 submissions it's
impossible for you to read all the
abstracts in the time allotted and so
you have to go by the titles and what
that means for you as an author is that
the title might be a primary mechanism
for you to connect with the reviewers
that you're looking for so think
carefully about the title
the program chairs assign reviewers
their papers presumably based in large
part on their bids although having bid
on lots of conferences I have very
little evidence that my bids are
actually shaping which things get
assigned to me but I still do my bidding
reviewers read the papers write comments
and Supply ratings I'll give you a
glimpse of what that's like in a second
authors are allowed to respond briefly
to the reviews this is the so-called
author response period it's a very tight
time window in which you have a very
constrained amount of text to use to
respond to the reviews
object to mistakes answer questions and
things like that
then the program or area chair
stimulates discussion among the
reviewers about conflicts between the
reviewers or conflicts with the author
response and in general the idea is that
this discussion will get clarity on
whether the paper should be accepted
and then finally
the program committee does some magic to
arrive at the final program based on all
of this input
you might get a meta review that
provides some insight into the final
decision making but I can more or less
guarantee for you that in the end the
decision making might be pretty opaque
especially in the final stages
that's what we have to live with I guess
when we enter into the sort of Lottery
like NLP conference setup for reviewing
here's a look at the form that reviewers
are typically dealing with you know
these used to be based mainly in
structured data now it's more like
structured text the first box will ask
what is the paper about what
contributions does it make and what are
the main strengths and weaknesses this
is a great question because I think it's
trying to check in with the reviewer and
make sure they actually know what the
paper is about and what its
contributions are
after that come the important pieces
reasons to accept reasons to reject
For Better or Worse both of these will
be required boxes and reviewers will
think of something to type in both I
resist this particularly for reasons to
reject I have often typed into that box
I have no reasons to reject for papers I
simply wanted to support but I had to
enter some text in order to get the form
to be accepted alas
maybe a box for questions and additional
feedback for the authors this is where
the reviewers might pose direct
questions that they're hoping will get
resolved as part of the author response
period
missing references this can be kind of
touchy you want to cite all the work
that you can discover and people feel
really slighted when things are missing
and that can often lead you to get some
points off with reviewers typos grammar
style and presentation improvements you
would hope that this was kind of
secondary and then crucially the ratings
an overall recommendation which is maybe
the primary data point that shapes what
happens to your paper in the submission
process and then reviewer confidence
which you would hope was kind of
calibrating on how much the
recommendation should contribute to the
overall judgment
and then there'll be a text box for
confidential information you'll also
have such a text box as part of your
author response and this is your chance
to communicate directly with the
leadership of the conference about
problems that might have Arisen and
reviewers have the same option
author responses a complicated and often
bewildering part of this many of these
conferences allow authors to submit
short responses to the reviews
this is often done on a tight time
window and you have a very limited
number of characters you can enter
overall this is a rather uncertain
business but I think I can offer some
advice
first many people are cynical about
author responses since reviewers rarely
change their scores afterwards I
understand that but my overall
perspective is a bit more optimistic
even given one though item two it's bad
in terms of signaling not to submit a
response at all it sort of signals to
the group that you don't care I realize
this sounds kind of dismal because I'm
saying you have to submit something
otherwise you'll get in trouble but
whatever you do submit might not have an
impact
I think there is unfortunately some
truth to that but as as I said I'm
optimistic in particular for conferences
that have area chairs who are tasked
with stimulating discussion and writing
meta reviews for a small number of
papers the author response might have a
Major Impact I say this as someone who
has played the area chair role many
times I find the author response
invaluable because I have the reviews I
have the paper and I have now the author
response and I can balance them against
each other and use that to stimulate
discussion and get some clarity on what
I should recommend for the paper as a
whole so I always benefit and I think
I'm not alone and I hope that gives you
some motivation for thinking about
investing in the author response
NLP conferences as usual have some
complex rules about this about what you
can and can't say in your author
response
read the instructions if you have
questions about what you can do in a
particular case you should again seek
out an expert I I do feel it's
unfortunate that I have to at so many
points here recommend that you find an
expert because it sounds like a
conspiracy of insiders but that is the
sad State of Affairs the number one
thing that comes to mind here is that
often there's a rule against reporting
new results
I'm not sure why that rule exists as an
area chair I want as much information as
I can get about these papers including
new results if they're available but
they're often forbidden but then the
question is what counts as a new result
and for that you might want your expert
to at least offer you some guidance
always be polite it can be hard but it
pays to be polite be firm and direct but
do that strategically to Signal what you
feel most strongly about
never ever ever write things like your
inattentiveness is embarrassing section
6 does what you say we didn't do
you can write that at once if it would
be cathartic but then delete it and
replace it with something like thank you
the information you're requesting is in
section six we will make this more
prominent or in our revision you're not
giving any ground you're making it clear
what you had achieved but you're also
being polite and productive and with
luck everyone feels validated by this
process and your scores get boosted a
little bit
presentation types and venues there are
kind of two Dimensions to this first for
the type you have oral versus poster
nobody knows how that's assigned the
conference people decide somehow and
you're told you're doing a poster or an
oral I don't think this is so
consequential at this point because what
matters is the papers
for presentation venue you have Workshop
versus main conference and that is an
important distinction there are
trade-offs here workshops tend to be
less prestigious and selective
but the bright side is that you get to
connect with a community of like-minded
people you might add a workshop interact
with people who become lifelong
collaborators
on the flip side the main conference
will be highly selective and very
prestigious but it will be absolutely
overwhelming the number of people will
be enormous it will be in some big
conference Hotel you might have real
trouble connecting with people and
finding people who work on what you do
your presentation might get lost in the
mix all of that stuff so you have to
decide on what experience you're looking
for and what your goals are
for Relevant conferences I've listed out
a whole bunch of them here the left
column is the ACL conferences the top
three ACL knackle and mnlp are think by
consensus the most prestigious in the
field
just below them are aacl and eacl but I
think we're nearing the point where
those are just in the top mix and people
are just looking for the next conference
to submit to as the year goes around
below those are Connell and coaling
which are great I think they're just
second tier but lots of important work
appears there I've published there I
actually think they're wonderful venues
and they give you a balance between a
workshop and a main conference and then
in terms of prestige below them as
workshops but I do feel that that's a
different enough Dimension to all this
that you should think about them
especially if you're thinking about a
first venue for publishing
in the middle I have conferences devoted
to kind of the web and knowledge bases
and artificial intelligence cognitive
science Linguistics these are all venues
that are great and that will welcome
NLP oriented submissions and I think the
most prestigious ones are kind of at the
top there right now and then on the
right I have what I think are by
consensus the top three machine learning
conferences and all of them are really
welcoming of NLP research you just might
want to orient it toward a slightly
broader audience but those are certainly
good homes for research you might be
doing
here is my personal assessment of NLP
reviewing another bit of editorializing
first I would say that the focus on
conference papers has been good for the
field it fits with and encourages a
rapid pace and even though I worry about
the Relentless pace of research I do
appreciate that things move fast and
it's a very Lively area intellectually
before about 2010 the reviewing in the
field was admirably good and rigorous in
comparison with other fields I say this
as someone who is coming from
Linguistics and cognitive science I was
deeply impressed by the investment
reviewers would make in these
submissions in that pre-deep learning
era especially
lately though the growth of the field
has reduced the general quality of
reviewing I think by consensus we all
see that this is happening the field is
still grappling with this it was
inevitable as you get larger and larger
numbers of submissions and reviewers
that the quality would go down as we
move from a kind of trusted group of
experts out into a much more diffuse and
diverse population
so that is all feeling like this as a
more of a lottery aspect to it when you
submit to these conferences
this next point I wanted to just issue a
warning and kind of connect with you on
this reviewers are occasionally
incredibly mean
you need to kind of desensitize yourself
to this and one way to do that would be
to share your reviews and your
experiences with an experienced NLP or
most likely that person will say I'm
really sorry that you had to get this
feedback do not take it personally we've
all seen this I worry about this point
reviewers can be mean enough that I
worry it could turn people off of the
field entirely it could send a signal
especially to people new to the field
that they don't belong and I think that
is tragic
don't do this if you're asked to review
be kind imagine what it would like to be
like to be on the receiving end and then
if you do receive this very mean
feedback don't take it personally it's
really hard for me to say this because
the whole point is that you've really
invested in your research and so to say
that you shouldn't take it personally
feels like a conflict on that point but
you have to kind of get to that point
but please please please if someone is
mean to you just try to move on from it
and keep contributing
it's more about the reviewers than it's
about you
this is more mundane forcing every paper
to be four or eight pages that is short
and long submission is not good but
luckily the issue is being addressed
productively with more use of
supplementary materials I love that
we're moving into a mode of science
where the papers are short and the
appendices run to 30 pages so that if
you need information about the details
you yourself can do a deep dive on the
appendix but if you're just trying to
understand the ideas and contribution
you can read a short paper
the biggest failing of all of this is
that there is no chance for authors to
appeal to an editor and interact with
that editor that's a missing piece that
journals provide and to good effect
there is one area for this transactions
of the ACL is a journal that follows the
standard ACL conference model fairly
closely but allows for Journal style
interaction with the editor I've been
heavily involved with tactical over the
years as an action editor and as a
reviewer and I think it is a shining
example of what reviewing in the field
could be if we scaled the model up to
the level of our conferences
on titles this is a smaller point I'm
using this paper I'm using titles in
scientific journals and article citation
which you will notice is not a jokey
paper title jokey paper titles are
somewhat risky
you should calibrate the title to the
scope of your contribution and you
should consider especially the reviewers
you're likely to attract as they are
scanning that long list of papers to bid
on
avoid special fonts and formatting
because they just won't travel with your
paper and so it can get kind of awkward
although I do have a soft spot for some
of the Emojis people have put in their
titles recently
abstracts this is also important this
will create a first impression for your
work here is a kind of template for
thinking about these documents the
opening is a broad overview a glimpse at
the central problem
the middle takes Concepts mentioned in
the opening and elaborates on them
probably by connecting with specific
experiments and results from the paper
this is the meat of it
the close establishes links between your
proposal and broader theoretical
concerns so that the reviewer has an
answer to the question does the abstract
offer a substantive and original
proposal
so that's a way to think about this here
it isn't kind of abstract this opening
sentence situates you dear reader
our approach seeks to address the
following Central issue then you spell
out the techniques we used our
experiments are these and you give
details and then overall we find that
our approach has the following
properties and the significance of this
is if you can conceptually fill this out
with details from your project I think
you're in a good place and then you
could decide to get a little creative if
you want to
style sheets or on avoiding desk rejects
this is mundane but important pay
attention to the details of the style
sheet and other requirements included in
the call for papers they change these
details all the time almost like they're
running some kind of experiment on us
and you don't want to get rejected for a
small infraction right if you break one
rule you could get the dreaded desk
reject which would be a tragic but short
way to end your conference submission
process for this round try to avoid that
and then finally the camera ready
version this is such a comical phrase
it's so weird that camera ready survives
this is like talking about dialing your
phone and so forth what this referred to
is it refers to as Antiquated technology
they used to literally take a picture of
your paper and that would be the
publication version that was the camera
ready part now it just sticks around as
a weird idiom
for most NLP conferences you get an
additional page on acceptance presumably
to respond to requests made by reviewers
though in practice you can use the space
however you like do write by review your
reviewers if they had concerns it's
great to address them but it is not a
contract that you have with the
reviewers ultimately at this stage you
should do what you feel is right for
your paper you have this extra page use
it wisely use it thoughtfully
in general the extra page is probably
for fixing things that were overly terse
because you compressed what was a long
paper down to a short one
but it's great if you have space to
express some new ideas and so forth
however
err on the side of saving brand new
results for subsequent Publications your
paper is already crammed enough I'm
guessing and so you don't want to add
more things in just because you've
discovered them it might be a good idea
to publish the current paper and then
begin thinking about the next
contribution that you'll make